now we just spoke on the phone with
mayor of Jefferson City her name is
Carrie Turgeon she has been up all night
inspecting the damage from that tornado
we're hearing reports of catastrophic
damage there is that how you would
describe it yes that's a good way to
describe it certainly catastrophic very
white for advantage it's we have large
trees down in several areas of the city
and several neighborhoods we have
buildings that have lost roofs walls
windows glass everywhere power lines
down so we have some significant damage
yeah we're hearing that there are no
reports of deaths at this time but there
are injuries can you tell us about the
number of injuries and the kind of
injuries that people have there well
thankfully like you said we the reports
that we are getting so far indicate that
there are no deaths and we are we've
been praying for that we're still very
thankful for that
the injuries so far from what I
understand there has not been any
significant injuries and when you see
the amount of damage it's hard to
believe but I believe that everybody did
the warnings the outdoor warning sirens
works were effective and people were
taking care of their neighbors and
making sure that they were seeking cover
and it happened around you know 11:30
p.m. so those people were already in bed
are just getting events so it was a time
when everybody was was aware of what was
going on
does the storm affected your family
personally personally yes my little
brother lost his business that was kind
of devastating for the family and we are
entrepreneurs and business people and
and so to lose that was very hard on him
but like him and many others that have
lost their their business and their
buildings you know buildings can be
replaced the people can't he's ok
everybody so far it's ok
we keep hearing that you guys aren't out
of the woods yet that the severe weather
threat is still in place so what's your
message to your constituents right now
for constituents fate they need to take
care of themselves we don't want them
out here just to look and see the damage
you know we need to take care of our
neighbors and focus on each other right
now we already know that we're in
a flood advisory we declared a state of
emergency near yesterday because of
significant flooding at the Missouri
River we've evacuated people from from a
portion of the city because of that so
we're already bracing for flooding
that's what we've been focusing on this
was completely unexpected so now our
focus is going to be on just picking up
the pieces and getting this back
together and getting Jefferson City back
together an air carry Turgeon I know you
have a lot of work to do we thank you
for taking the time to speak to us and
good luck here good luck
thank you we'll be praying thank you